So how do we identify who
the owner in the group are?
If we look back at our
directory listing,
we'll see two columns,
here in the middle.
Most of the entries read
student student, but
there's one here that reads root root,
and I'll come back to that one.
These two columns identify the owner and
the group for each entry in this list.
Now it's important to remember, although
each of these has the same word,
student, listed in the two columns,
they're in two entirely
different things.
The system has a username student,
which is the owner of the file.
And a group name student,
which was automatically created
when we made this user.
This is pre-common practice
on a Linux system,
to have a group name
the same as the user.
Just remember that they are two
entirely different things.
So, what's up with this entry
here that has root root?
We can see that the entry's name is ..,
and that's just a shortcut for
the parent directory.
And we know we're in our
student's home directory.
So this entry here,
is the equivalent of /home.
That directory is owned by the root
user, and has a group of root.
And if we look at the permissions,
we see that only the root user
can write to that directory.
let's test this out for ourselves.
I'll move into the directory using cd..
And then I'll try to write a file.
You'll get a permission denied error,
just as this permission
system told us we would.
Only root is allowed to
write in this directory.
And our current user's
definitely not root.
We can still list the files in this
directory, because we have read access,
and we even entered the directory
because we have execute.
We just can't write.